hey guys welcome back to the channel and
today's video is gonna be the start of a
little mini series that I came up with
this mini series is basically going to
explain how to defeat every character in
for honor and kind of want to watch out
for them so the first video for this
topic is going to be about all the
assassins I was going to do factions but
then I realized that doing them by group
is a lot better so for example this
video is gonna be about the assassins
and then next to video down on the
comments below you guys can tell me
which one I should do next or if I kind
of get like an even viewer something
like that then I'll just do the one that
I was originally going to plan for but
if you guys want to see a certain topic
more than another please tell me in the
comments below so I can make the video
for all of you but today's video like
title states is going to be about the
assassins
now the assassins group is comprised of
three characters peacekeeper Berserker
and Orochi now there are a lot of things
similar with them and a lot of things
that are very different with them but
we'll go over that in a second so the
first character on this this is gonna be
about peacekeeper now this is definitely
one of the most annoying characters you
go on reddit you'll see people complain
about peacekeeper a lot with her light
attack spam but we'll get into that one
a few things you want to look out for
when you're against a peacekeeper is
look at the range that you're fighting
around think about it if a peacekeeper
has two daggers that aren't very really
as big as your arm why would you want to
be within a range of like a law bringer
like a spear what she's going to do is
this dash attack that I will be showing
you on screen is where she dashes
forward and then stabs you with the
right trigger I do I kind of forgot what
the name is any peacekeeper players can
explain what that is but basically what
she does she dashes forward and then
stabs you and the up guard stance and it
will always be in the upper guard stance
nowhere else so if you see her from a
medium to long distance you know
something out of the ordinary with her
she's probably going to throw out that
hit so just always have your garden in
the top or be ready to flick it up just
in case one of the few things that
they'll also do is try to fake it where
they dash forward and then
like faint but then they'll go for a
guard break that's more high-level play
but always just be aware to either guard
up or press X to guard break if you're
really good at the timing all of this
stuff can be easily achieved by just
going to a duel practice or training a
bot or even trading with a teammate to
repeatedly keep you guessing and you'll
get way better at this if she uses her
light attack spam which is basically
repeatedly throwing the right bumper or
the light attack in different stances to
confuse you just re cooperate double tap
a and back up don't dash forward don't
dash to the side just back up just dash
backwards you know kind of recuperate
understand what the hell is going on and
then do a bunch of moves that are really
confusing if you don't understand what I
mean if you've ever seen a Ken say do a
swift strike where he dashes to the
right and then slashes in that direction
or a row cheese - and slash I call it
where he'll dash to the right do like a
little like a little 360 and then swipe
stuff like that will easily throw off a
peacekeeper and then make them not be
able to attack if they're guarded or if
they're too busy gardening if they're
focused on guarding you then they won't
be focused on hitting you and that's
kind of what you want one of the nice
things about the assassins though is
that all three of them do have a small
health pool so it kind of got they kind
of yeah it's kind of how to balance it
they have small health but a really fast
attacks I kind of like how they did
balance that so just just to you know
keep your distance use the fast and
disorienting moves to confuse her to
prevent her from attacking you and
always be aware of that that jump
forward and heavy attack so the next
character is Dierker now I did read from
reddit who someone has played over a
hundred hours with and they did give
some good pointers on how to play as
them but I twisted it around and saw
ways that you can counter them Berserker
has two axes do wielded axes and but the
problem with Berserker is that he is a
super short-range his axes don't go very
far axes aren't really that big in
general so he can't really swing it like
once again just like peacekeeper their
weapons aren't that big so if they're
from
'i'm distance beware of like a guard
break or a dash forward or something but
his long heavy attack he has a heavy
attack where he goes up in the air and
he slices you down with both of his axes
this is easily readable and easy pair
easily parried it's super slow some
things to look out for for Berserker are
these unlimited blade attacks where he
basically just spins in 360s constantly
and just keeps hitting you he might get
a few shots off or you just guard maybe
the rest of them it's kind of hard to
determine how to like guard it I mean I
haven't really faced too many berserkers
that have done this move so I can't
really explain how to look out for it
but they'll always be like I said before
the dash forward and the guard breaks
you know he'll dash forward hit you with
a couple pick hit you with a couple
attacks then maybe guard break you to
throw you off one of the things you have
to realize with these assassins is that
they're super quick and nimble on their
feet so if you ever tried to go for a
heavy attack especially with a vanguard
or a heavy class maybe not really
warlord but he still he still might be
in there if you swing from the top all
they have to do is - to the left or
right and then they can completely
punish you for it
Orochi can do is - and slash peacekeeper
can back up and then come back forward
and guard break you same with Berserker
with his unlimited unlimited blade dance
and just like you know just like I said
before he does have a small help so do
be aware that all these assassins are
going to throw you off they're gonna
keep dodging you left and right they're
gonna try to confuse you as best as they
can to throw you off and then kill you
right after now the last character for
the assassins is Orochi I see all the
time when dreaded everyone's complaining
about roachie being too quick so I kind
of I kind of threw it together an idea
now like I said before small health pool
so few attacks did throw him off will
kill him immediately and put him into a
more of a defensive stance he has this
one attack you would really want to look
out for called the storm rush
once again it'll be up on the screen as
I'm talking about this but he dashes
backwards holds his sword at his hip and
then swings when he lets go
what this does is basically he dashes
forward swings and then he kind of like
Kirk turns around the around the person
it's basically a guard break they get a
few extra hits in the interest thing
about this one that I found out is
whatever stance he's in before he does
that storm rush is the stance he's gonna
be in when he uses it and you can tell
which way he's gonna swing by the
direction of the sword on his hip so if
you're looking at the Orochi and the
sword is to your left or his right it's
going to be the left guard stance for
you if it's on his left and your right
it's gonna be on your right guard stance
it will never be in the up position it
can't be in the up position it'll always
be right or left and once again a couple
a few of his attacks are easily Perea
bull orochi's got some really slow heavy
attack that can really do some damage to
you but it's still easily parried which
leaves him open for some attacks there's
kind of be careful like just just like
with berserker - if you tried to go with
the top heavy gauged easily - and punish
you for it - just be aware with that so
those are all the three characters just
for a general overview limit the amount
of heavy attacks you do from the top
especially against these characters do
more moves that kind of confuse them to
make them too fast kind of like Ken's a
swift strike to throw them off so that
they're more in the defensive a style
attack the defensive play style instead
of an attack toi style if you try to
keep your distance if you're like a wall
bringer or any like hybrid character
with a spear try to be out of try to be
within range so that you can hit them
but they can't hit you so that's two -
forward because usually when that -
forwards are gonna go for that guard
break and then you can tek it easily and
just just be aware with these characters
they do have a small health pool but
they are very nimble and very quick
they're probably the most annoying class
in the whole game probably the most
picked class in the whole game that's
why I did them first cuz you know
there's always gonna be people trying to
figure out how the [ __ ] do I stop this
character and then look up on YouTube
and then here you got my guide so there
you all have it for the assassins I hope
you all did enjoy and I hope you all did
learn something if you are ever confused
or this didn't help you
go into a bot duel or going to a duel
not just the duel practice one of you
won a bot in custom match and then pick
one of the three you're having trouble
with let's say that you got beserker
style like against you've played against
a bunch of missouri's you got his style
down quick peacekeeper you're having a
little bit of trouble with go to custom
match load up a 1v1 set the rounds to 99
you don't have to do all 99 but just you
don't have to keep resetting go to 99
rounds 1v1 the Peacekeeper and then set
the difficulty to like two two is
basically the standing point of most
players three is when it gets really
difficult so if you want to challenge
yourself go for a level three four if
you really want to improve but I'm just
saying the level threes are [ __ ]
annoying and everyone knows about that
too
so just be aware but like I said just go
to the custom match if you guys do have
a problem with that but I hope you all
did enjoy this video and just like I
said in the comments below in the
comments just tell me what other classes
you want to do the Vanguard the hybrid
and then the heavies we only have three
you only have three others besides this
if you guys did like the video but do
please be sure to leave a like guys and
then if you did enjoy this video and you
want to see more subscribe for more
I'm always putting out the four on our
content to help out everybody I'll see
you all later guys peace out